[Music]
[Music]
official rob tell us returning home this
afternoon in a paper jumpsuit sources
tell eight news now investigators had
spent part of the day questioning him
about the murder of review journal
investigative reporter jeff gearman good
afternoon thank you so much for joining
us at four i'm kirstjen joy and i'm
brian loftis we have a lot to cover
tonight the eight news now investigators
with team coverage david charms here
with more on what jeff gearman uncovered
but first we head out live to vanessa
murphy she's been outside of the home
all day after police spent all morning
and afternoon searching his home vanessa
detectives are zeroing in on public
administrator robert tellis in this
homicide case the victim investigative
journalist jeff gearman now as far as we
know telus is inside this home right now
police dropped him off a short while ago
i tried talking with him
did you do this did you commit this
murder
did you do this tell us anything
why did police go away your vehicle
do you have a comment
telus was with investigators while
police searched his home as they look
for clues in the stabbing death of
review journal investigative journalist
jeff german he was found stabbed to
death outside his home saturday two
vehicles were towed from the home of
telus one of them appearing to be
similar from this vehicle placed near
the scene of the murder police also
released this video of the suspect talis
and gearman have a history gearman
reporting on problems within the public
administrator's office including
exposing a possible affair telus then
lost his bid for re-election in the
democratic primary now telus was not
happy with german's coverage he tweeted
about it so again that is one link
police are looking at back to you
vanessa when you tried talking with him
he was wearing a white jumpsuit do you
know why
police took his clothes and then gave
him that white paper jumpsuit again
right now he is a free man i want to be
clear he is not facing charges at this
time he was not arrested again as far as
we know he is still inside his home here
but again police will continue their
detective work they took his clothes
they took at least a couple of vehicles
and whatever else from this house back
to you